Russia has signed a deal with Belarus to
station tactical nuclear weapons in its
territory defense minister Sergey shoigu
says the decision was taken after what
he called a sharp escalation on Russia's
borders
speak now to journalist Julia
shappavalova she's in Moscow and how
does the Russian side explain this
deployment of tactical nuclear weapons
into Belarus
so defense minister shoinger explained
the move to deploy a Russia's
non-strategic nuclear weapons on the
territory of Belarus by saying that the
activity of NATO and its nuclear
missions is forcing Russia and Belarus
to take retaliatory measures according
to the Russian defense minister the
process of deployment is ready to begin
the Belarusian site has received the
iskander missile system capable of using
both conventional and nuclear weapons
also part of the Belarusian aircraft has
been modified for the possible use of
nuclear weapons plus Belarus servicemen
have undergone some specific training
that's what we hear from minister shoigu
at the same time Russia won't give
control over its tactical nuclear
weapons to Belarus and the decision to
use the weapons will also remain with
Moscow by the way the decision was first
announced by President Putin back in
March and now we see how it is being
implemented a lot of criticism over this
move what might be the consequences of
it
uh what we hear now Russian analysts say
that despite a popular belief in the
west that tactical nuclear weapons do
not play a serious role in Russian
nuclear deterrence with the deployment
of nuclear weapons and Belarus things
change and we can talk about a serious
shift in the Russian nuclear Doctrine
there is a clear signal to Nato that
Russia is increasing its Reliance on
nuclear weapons and more specifically on
the issue of where weapons on the
battlefield on the the use of of the
tactical nuclear weapons on the
battlefield so the conclusion is that
the move is quite serious and raises
certain concern
thank you very much joining us there
from Moscow